je l'ai dit vous avez pris finalement un
carton rouge et la France par contre ne
peut
alors monsieur le ministre en conclure à
Caen des économies
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Dominique verrière pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
madame la ministre la Terre est-elle
plate cette question vous paraît absurde
et pourtant certaines voix estiment
qu'après tout toutes les affirmations
aussi complotistes et farfelues
soient-elles mérite d'être débattue pire
encore comme je l'ai entendu sur France
Inter hier matin elle devrait être
considérée comme des thèses minoritaires
comme les autres qui seraient donc des
thèses majoritaires elles auraient ainsi
leur place dans le débat public aux
côtés de Fès scientifiquement validées
un mélange des gens particulièrement
dangereux aux conséquences parfois
désastreuses en particulier dans le
domaine de la santé où certains vous
expliquent que le cancer se soigne par
le jeûne ou que les vaccins sont un
outil de contrôle mental des populations
des charlatans profitent de certains
pour leur vendre des pseudothérapies
inefficaces et dangereuse quand elle
conduisent à un refus de soins
conventionnels des stratégies
pernicieuses qui sous le prétexte du
bien-être mettent peu à peu leur victime
sous emprise et les entraînent dans un
engrenage sectaire qui peut devenir
immortel l'un d'entre eux a été
récemment mis en examen mais n'est-ce
pas l'arbre qui cache la forêt et que
dire des mutuelles qui rembourse des
médecines dites alternatives sans
contrôle sérieux madame la ministre
l'État est-il suffisamment armé pour
lutter notre position vis-à-vis de ses
dérives sectaires quasiment unique au
monde peut-être se conjuguer
efficacement avec la législation
européenne
[Applaudissements]
tu as la secrétaire des tâches chargée
de la citoyenneté madame Sonia baquet
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice va d'abord je vous remercie
d'avoir participé à ces assises qui
étaient extrêmement riches et un moment
important et attendu par tout cette
toutes ces personnes qui défendent les
victimes et ces dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont touchées chaque année
par ces dérives sectaires effectivement
ces assises ont fait l'objet d'un
certain donner un certain nombre de
propositions et la première d'entre
elles c'est la question de la prévention
comment nos compatriotes peuvent-ils
croire de la même manière le fait
scientifique que un certain nombre de
croyances et pour répondre à ça nous
avons eu des engagements forts de la
secrétaire d'État Sarah et l'aéri sur le
travail qu'on a à faire en matière
d'éducation à l'information de nos plus
jeunes pour lesquels finalement on a pas
forcément
évoluer du passage de l'information
traditionnelle aux réseaux sociaux un
gros travail qui va être mené avec les
plateformes pour éviter que celle-ci
contribue à
soutenir c'est ces dérives là et puis un
gros travail de communication et puis
après il y a un travail particulier en
matière de santé à effectuer puisque on
sait très bien que l'explosion de ces
dérives se passe surtout en matière de
santé et il y a une annonce forte qui a
été faite pardon par le ministère de la
de la santé par la voix d'Agnès Firmin
le Bodo avec l'encadrement absolument
indispensable des pratiques non
conventionnelles de soins puisqu'en fait
nos compatriotes ont accès à tout un tas
de praticiens de naturopathe qui pour
lesquelles les pratiques ne sont
absolument pas vérifiées et puis il y a
tout un travail pardon d'accompagnement
des victimes qui attendent une
indemnisation et puis un travail de
sur les auteurs puisque les auteurs
doivent être plus sévèrement punis vous
l'avez dit il y a des mises en examen il
y a des condamnations mais on a besoin
de renforcer notre arsenal pénal et je
compte sur vous les parlementaires et
ici au Sénat en particulier pour
soutenir ce renforcement de notre
arsenal législatif pour condamner ces
gourous et ses charlatans je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre de votre
réponse effectivement l'arsenal pénal
est peut-être à renforcer en France mais
je crois que il faut réellement
travailler sur la suggestion sur
l'emprise et savoir convaincre
probablement aussi la CEDH que une
personne sous emprise n'est pas une
personne libre que si on a effectivement
toute liberté parce que de choisir une
religion c'est un droit fondamental il
faut savoir que subir une suggestion par
contre peut-être un vrai danger mortel
merci
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente ici pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologie ils
avaient la parole madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre hier vous affirmiez
devant les députés que chacun devait
assumer ses choix je vous demande donc
aujourd'hui d'assumer les vôtres celui
du coup de force anti-démocratique celui
de la régression sociale depuis deux
mois le peuple vous dit non les grèves
et manifestations se multiplient sur
tout le territoire et demeure ce
qu'elles ont toujours été des outils du
progrès social hier vous avez répondu
avec nervosité à mon ami André
Chassaigne en lui reprochant d'opposer
la légitimité de la rue à celle du
Parlement mais vous qui aimez vous
rappelez votre passé de gauche dois-je
vous rappeler que c'est la grève et la
rue qui ont bâti des conquêtes sociales
sans remonter jusqu'à 1789
contestez-vous les grèves de 1906 pour
la journée de travail à 8h
contestez-vous la légitimité des grèves
de 1936 et la victoire des congés payés
contestez-vous les formidables progrès
suite au mouvement de 68 à sa grève
massive à la mobilisation de la jeunesse
enfin plus proche de nous les victoires
de 95 face à la réforme des retraites de
Monsieur Juppé de 2006 pour effacer le
CPE non-elle pas confirmé la force du
mouvement social et sa légitimité oui
madame la Première ministre il existe
une légalité résultant d'une élection
mais il existe une légitimité sociale
que vous ne pouvez pas nier et qui
aujourd'hui s'impose à vous oui le recul
de l'âge du départ à la retraite est
refusé par notre peuple vous avez fait
un choix de société un choix de droites
un choix de classe le débat eu au moins
le mérite de clarifier l'échiquier
politique des droites de renaissance à
LR minoritaire électoralement ensemble
vous avez pris les reines par un acte
d'autoritarisme dangereux pour la
démocratie que devrait confirmer la CMP
réunis depuis ce matin madame la
Première ministre nous ne le serons pas
faire nous ne lâcherons rien y compris
avec les moyens constitutionnels qui
sont à notre disposition
merci
pour vos répondre la parole est à madame
la Première ministre Madame Elisabeth
borne merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la Présidente Eliane assassy il y
a quelque chose de grave à opposé
systématiquement la légitimité de la rue
à celle du Parlement
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose de dangereux à
tenté par tout moyen d'empêcher le débat
de le bloquer
[Applaudissements]
la gauche sénatoriale la gauche
sénatoriale a revendiqué un seul
objectif empêcher un vote sur le texte
vous n'avez pas réussi de longs débats
ont eu lieu tous les articles ont été
examinés et le projet de loi a été
adopté à une large majorité
madame la Présidente assassin évidemment
j'aurais préféré plus de débats de fonds
et moins de procédures plus de débats
d'idées et moins de posture vous en avez
décidé autrement je le regrette mais
c'est ainsi et c'est le fait unique de
ce qui devient la nuit pêche sénatoriale
[Applaudissements]
je veux
je veux à cet égard
je veux à cet égard saluer latitude
responsable de la majorité sénatoriale
pour la bonne tenue des discussions dans
les mystiques
vous avez pu vous pencher
vous avez pu vous pencher sur tous les
articles et enrichir le texte de
nombreuses propositions notamment pour
améliorer les pensions des femmes ou en
faveur de l'emploi des seniors vous avez
également pu faire votre de nombreux
amendements déposés lors de l'examen à
l'Assemblée madame la Présidente
assassine quand j'entends certains
parlementaires de la nupesse qualifié le
processus démocratique en cours de prise
d'otages des Français j'y vois une
entreprise de disqualification de nos
institutions particulièrement
insupportables venant d'élus de la
nation
[Applaudissements]
pour ma part j'ai le plus grand respect
pour le travail parlementaire qui se
poursuit en ce moment même en commission
mixte paritaire
et je suis convaincu que le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale peuvent s'accorder
pour un projet qui garantira l'avenir de
nos retraites par répartition qui
réduira l'écart de pension entre les
femmes et les hommes qui augmentera les
petites retraites qui fermera les
principaux régimes spéciaux qui
améliorera l'emploi des seniors qui
protégera ceux qui sont
usés par le travail qui permettra à ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt de
partir plus tôt cette réforme est
nécessaire elle a été enrichie notamment
grâce aux travaux de votre assemblée et
avec mon gouvernement nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés pour que dans les
prochains jours une majorité vote la
réforme des retraites je vous remercie
la parole des tabadables Samantha
casbone pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre des Sports l'Institut
de la jeunesse et de l'éducation
populaire a rendu public jeudi 3 mars un
baromètre national des pratiques
sportives pour l'année 2022 dont les
résultats sont très encourageants 60%
des Français de 15 ans et plus ont
pratiqué une activité physique et
sportive en moyenne une fois par semaine
au cours des 12 derniers 12 derniers
mois soit 6 points de plus qu'en 2018
malheureusement ces résultats ont pu
être occultés par les profondes crises
de gouvernance qu'on traversait
certaines institutions du sport français
depuis quelques années notamment les
fédérations françaises de rugby et de
football le sport est vecteur d'unité et
d'émancipation il rend possible une
société rassemblée autour de valeurs
essentielles telles que l'équité
l'esprit l'inclusion le respect et la
persévérance et rien ne doit entacher le
projet politique et sociétal qu'il porte
en lui alors que la France se prépare à
accueillir des événements sportifs
mondiaux majeurs la Coupe du monde de
rugby à la fin de l'année et les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques à l'été 2024
il apparaît donc nécessaire de
promouvoir des valeurs sportives
irréprochables ma question madame la
ministre porte sur la réforme de la
gouvernance des fédérations sportives un
comité national pour renforcer l'éthique
dans le sport vient d'être créé et ses
membres vient d'être désignés vous
pourriez-vous préciser quel va être le
fonctionnement de ce comité ainsi que
ses missions précises et ses objectifs
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre des Sports des Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques
Samantha casse bonne en effet les
derniers mois ont été marqués par une
série de crises dans le sport français
qui ont mis en exergue la nécessité
d'améliorer la gouvernance de ce sport
et notamment des fédérations sportives
mais
il est clair absolument clair que c'est
zermans constataient ne peuvent pas se
reproduire s'agissant d'organisation qui
sont délégataires d'une mission de
service public et qui ont la
responsabilité d'une partie de notre
jeunesse mais il est clair aussi et
merci d'avoir rappelé que ça ne doit pas
éluder les progrès dans la pratique
sportive l'engagement remarquable des
bénévoles des éducateurs sportifs et
aussi que beaucoup de fédérations vont
bien avancent bien ainsi que les progrès
la démocratie sportive qui ont été
notamment impulsées par la loi du 2 mars
2022 qui a instauré la parité au niveau
des instances dirigeantes du sport
français et aussi permis le vote des
clubs pour les assembler général
électives maintenant cette amélioration
de la gouvernance il faut la prolonger
poursuivre l'amplifier c'est le sens de
ce comité national pour renforcer
l'éthique et la démocratie dans le sport
que j'ai mis en place qui va être qu'aux
présidé par Marie-Georges Buffet et par
Stéphane Diagana il va être composé de
10 autres personnalités qualifiées
incontestable venant d'horizon divers je
pense à Jean-François Lamour je pense à
Arsène Wenger je pense à notre arbitre
pionnière Stéphanie frappard je pense
aussi à une grande dame comme Isabelle
Autissier ce comité aura la
responsabilité de me faire des
propositions pour l'automne prochain en
faisant un très grand nombre d'auditions
et il aura la responsabilité à l'automne
de me livrer un certain nombre de
conclusions autour de trois axes une
gouvernance du sport qui soit plus
éthique plus démocratique avec plus de
débats plus de pluralisme et aussi plus
protectrice des pratiquantes et des
pratiquants notamment sur la thématique
des violences à caractère sexiste et
sexuels je vous remercie merci bonhomme
de minuit madame cachebonne
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Rémy
Cardon pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain il y avait la
parole
madame la Première ministre monsieur du
stop disait hier devant les députés je
le cite pour atteindre le port il faut
un cap ce cap progrès justice équilibre
pour ne retraite nous le cherchons
toujours et ce n'est pas le simulacre de
démocratie que vous avez offert au
Parlement qui nous a permis de nous en a
rapproché premièrement les retraités ne
verront jamais leur 1200 euros une homme
de pension de retraite longtemps promise
voilà votre vision vision du progrès
deuxièmement les femmes continueront de
toucher des pensions de retraite
inférieure à celle des hommes en moyenne
39%, voilà votre vision de la justice
troisièmement vous faites reposer tous
les efforts sur une seule génération
sans jamais solliciter le patronat voilà
votre vision de l'équilibre madame la
Première ministre une chose est sûre
nous ne partageons pas le même cap et
nous sommes des millions à refuser
d'embarquer avec la droite sénatoriale
sur ce radeau de la Méduse vous faites
l'unanimité et l'unité contre vous
l'unanimité des syndicats des
travailleurs des millions de personnes
qui descendent dans les rues chaque
semaine qui votent la réduction des
grèves la reconduction et qu'il
lâcheront rien
j'aimerais vous demander madame la
Première ministre finalement pour qui et
avec qui gouvernez-vous
ce que vous proposez consciemment ou
inconsciemment d'ailleurs c'est
l'alternative mortifère à savoir la
préparation du terrain à la prise de
pouvoir du rassemblement national
bref il me reste à vous demander madame
la Première ministre êtes-vous des
inconscients ou des irresponsables
pour vous répondre la parole
ministre du Travail du plein emploi
d'insertion vous avez la parole merci à
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Cardon vous dites que vous ne
partagez pas notre sentiment que vous ne
partagez pas notre réforme nous nous
sommes convaincus que cette réforme à
une majorité cette réforme a une
majorité parce que elle peut être votée
par tous ceux et toutes celles qui
souhaitent sauver et préserver le
système par répartition cette réforme a
aussi une majorité parce qu'elle peut
être votée par tous ceux qui sont prêts
à aménager et faire en sorte de mieux
protéger à la fois ceux qu'on les
carrières les plus longues mais aussi
ceux qui ont les métiers les plus
exposés à l'usure professionnelle et à
la pénibilité cette réforme elle a une
majorité parce que telle de ceux qui
veulent la voter sont ceux qui veulent
faire en sorte que l'emploi des seniors
soit amélioré dans notre pays puis nous
ayons un taux d'activités qui puisse
augmenter et cette réforme elle sera
aussi votée par ceux qui sont attaché à
la revalorisation des petites retraites
vous en faites un cheval de bataille
monsieur le sénateur c'est la
démonstration que la gauche aujourd'hui
est déconnectée des classes populaires
avec cette réforme ce sont un million
800000 retraités actuels qui vont
bénéficier d'une revalorisation pouvant
aller de 25 à 100 €, ce sont 900000
parmi eux qui vont bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de 70 à 100 € par mois et
Monsieur sénateur nous parlons de
retraité quand 800 900 000 euros par
mois si vous considérez que une
augmentation de 70 80 ou 90 euros par
mois ça n'est rien pour eux c'est que
vous avez perdu le sens de la réalité
vous nous dites que nous serions
inconscients et responsables les
responsabilité dans votre camp elle est
dans votre camp quand vous ne faites
rien alors que le système est en train
de s'écrouler elle est en son temps
quand elle est dans votre camp quand
vous faites rien alors que ce que notre
réforme permet de sauver le système par
répartition Monsieur le Sénateur pendant
le débat donc vous n'avez visiblement
pas retenu grand chose vous avez eu des
mots assez outrancier comme vous en avez
à l'instant à l'égard de la Premier
ministre c'est la démonstration monsieur
le sénateur que la des esprits que j'ai
évoqués elle vous a gagné comme elle
gagne l'ensemble de la gauche française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre majorité c'est tout simplement
49-3
monsieur ministre si vous voulez en tout
cas sachez gouverner sans le peuple est
contre lui et ses représentants c'est
dangereux pour la démocratie c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec le groupe
socialiste nous allons déposer une
demande de RIB pour sauver la démocratie
pour sauver la République de vos Bayons
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Marc Philippe daubrais pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique les
la récente publication des chiffres de
la construction neuve pour 2022 confirme
ce que nous n'avons cessé de dire depuis
plusieurs mois plusieurs ici au
gouvernement la situation n'est pas
dramatique elle est catastrophique
rarement on a connu des chiffres aussi
dramatiques moins 25% pour les
promoteurs privés -30% pour les
constructions individuelles 350
000 unités prévues en 2023 pour mémoire
après le plan de relance de Jean-Louis
Borloo on était à 48600040 % de moins
annoncé pour l'année qui vient et ça va
continuer des faillites en cascade sont
annoncés dans la promotion pour le
logement social la réforme Funès des aPL
de la loi Elan a assécher les finances
des offices HLM et on est pour la
troisième année consécutive en dessous
des 100 000 logements sociaux
sans parler des mesures que vous avez
prises sur un certain nombre de sujets
par exemple zéro artificialisé à son net
heureusement que le Sénat est en train
de les corriger donc monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple est-ce
que vous avez prévu enfin un plan de
relance pour relancer la construction
neuve dans notre pays comme nous l'avons
fait avec succès sous Nicolas Sarkozy
Jackson qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu
des mesures fiscales de relance
exceptionnelle comme nous avons réussi à
le faire sous le gouvernement de
François Fillon
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Marc-Philippe de Brest d'abord quelques
chiffres très récents et qui seront
l'occasion de d'objectiver les choses on
a une augmentation des autorisations
en 2022 qui remonte à un niveau que nous
n'avions pas connu depuis plus de 6 ans
à plus de 480 000 en Hauses de 3% mais
dans le même temps on a une baisse des
mises en chantier de 3% à 376000 avec
les indications que vous donnez entre
les deux on a des phénomènes structurels
je vais revenir mais on a aussi un
phénomène conjoncturel qui est la très
forte augmentation des refus de prêt
dans un double contexte ou globalement
les taux d'intérêt sont passés de 1,5 à
3-20 sur 20 ans et ou dans le même temps
le coût moyen de la construction a
augmenté avec un effet d'inflation
généralisé en 2022 particulièrement vrai
dans le champ du logement premier sujet
à côté de ça par rapport à cette
question des prêts et de la baisse de la
demande puisque nous avons eu
39% de baisse de la demande au dernier
trimestre et ça c'est pas un sujet
gouvernemental la baisse de la demande
elle est liée à des acheteurs qui
cessent d'acheter pas à une absence
d'offre
la réforme du taux d'usure en faisant en
sorte de la mensualiser depuis le
premier février pour fluidifier une
partie du marché le premier élément de
réponse les réponses plus structurelles
elles seront prises dans la continuité
du CNR logement qui se termine au mois
d'avril nous discutons en ce moment avec
tous les professionnels vous en avez
cité un certain nombre il y en a
d'autres et dans ces autres il y a les
élus l'ambition du président de la
République c'est d'ouvrir le chantier de
la décentralisation du logement vous
connaissez parfaitement ces questions
vous les avez connues comme les lieux
local vous les avez connus comme membres
du gouvernement on a eu l'habitude de
réfléchir sur un combien là où la
disparité des situations fait que c'est
le ou et le comment qui mérite d'être
questionné et la décentralisation du
logement elle est au cœur d'une ambition
y compris sur la rénovation énergétique
dans un dialogue franc avec les communes
avec les intercommunalités et avec les
départements changements des zonage
décentralisation des dispositifs
soutient aux maires bâtisseurs ce sont
ces ensembles sur lesquels nous
travaillons
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
j'ai été en son temps ministre du
Logement il faut que vous révisiez vos
chiffres les notaires viennent de sortir
le dernier chiffre pour le dernier
trimestre 2022 par rapport à un an c'est
moins 25% les permis de construire
monsieur le ministre - 25 % annoncé je
veux prendre un seul chiffre si vous
rapportez le nombre de constructions
neuves à la population nombre de ménages
français c'est le plus bas chiffres que
nous allons connaître depuis 1951 ça
avait donné l'appel de l'abbé Pierre
monsieur ministre vous sous-estimez le
problème parce que vous êtes confronté à
des objectifs stratégiques
contradictoires il est grand temps que
le gouvernement se réveille
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
Concorde pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
Haïti pleurant tous les jours c'est mort
c'est blessés par dizaines Haïti affamé
a été livré aux mains de gang a été
assistant au viol de ces femmes Haïti
voyant ses enfants recrutés par des
groupes armés Haïti sans gouvernement
sans État s'enfonce inexorablement dans
le chaos et pourtant pas un mot de
l'État sous la situation de ce pays à
qui nous sommes tendre ce pays envers
lequel nous avons une dette morale comme
le disait si légitimement François
Hollande en 2015 première colonie noire
à prendre son indépendance en 1804 Haïti
a bien des égards a ouvert des chemins
repousser les limites du possible et ce
alors même qu'elle a été dès le départ
affublé du fardeau indigne d'une dette
insoutenable pour acheter sa liberté la
résolution adoptée par l'ONU en octobre
dernier constitué un pas symbolique mais
elle ne peut servir de refuge pour
justifier notre inaction collective
certains pays comme le Canada ont fait
le choix d'une politique plus active que
fait la France à 1h30 de vol des pays
français d'Amérique que fait l'Europe il
faut désormais aller plus loin que des
fonctions face au massacre des Haïtiens
devant le retrait des organisations
humanitaires qui baissent les bras une à
une il faut organiser la coopération
dans le bassin qui arrivait il faut oser
l'envoi d'une force de maintien de la
paix face au Massac quotidien de ces
villes haïtiens la tireur la famine dans
laquelle vit la population dans un état
désormais inexistant dois-je rappeler
qu'à la suite de l'assassinat du
président Moïse en 2017 Haïti n'a plus
de gouvernement combien de temps encore
pour nous attendre combien de morts
encore combien d'heures combien de viol
combien de drames avant d'agir
en charge du commerce extérieur des
Français de l'étranger Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice qu'on cogne d'abord je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
nous sommes d'accord sur un point la
situation en Haïti qui est très grave à
la fois sur le plan humanitaire sur le
plan sécuritaire et bien sûr sur le plan
politique en revanche il y a un point
sur lequel nous ne sommes pas d'accord
c'est l'inaction de la France aux côtés
des États-Unis et du Canada la France
est active c'est l'une des nations les
plus actives pour tenter d'aider les
Haïtiens nous le faisons notamment dans
le cadre du soutien à la police
nationale haïtienne et nous allons
encore accroître cette coopération et ce
soutien nous le faisons également dans
le cadre de l'aide humanitaire 8,5
millions d'euros d'aide humanitaires
dont 5 millions d'aides alimentaires qui
va directement aux Haïtiens enfin nous
sommes vous l'avez dit actif dans le
cadre de la diplomatie au niveau des
Nations unies dans le cadre de la
résolution
26 53 pour infliger les sanctions au
criminels qui sont les auteurs de ce que
vous dénonciez à l'instant notamment
ceux des gang enfin nous sommes à
l'écoute de nos partenaires s'agissant
du projet de force internationale
d'appui à la police nationale haïtienne
sur la forme qu'elle pourrait comprendre
et nous pouvons envisager d'y apporter
un soutien matériel et puis je voudrais
enfin terminer par le fait que la sortie
de crise implique et vous le savez un
accord inclusif entre les acteurs
politiques haïtiens la mise en place
récente du Haut Conseil de transition
doit permettre d'avancer vers des
élections comme prévu dans le document
de consensus national du 21 décembre
dernier c'est en tout cas ce que nous
souhaitons pour le bien d'Haïti merci
vous avez quelques secondes
je ne peux que déplorer
la discrétion la très grande discrétion
des actions que vous venez d'énumérer
mais c'est vrai Haïti à du pétrole ni
gaz
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
Dumas pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur depuis plus
d'une semaine Paris est devenu une ville
submergée par des montagnes de déchets
et oui mes chers collègues je ne vous
apprends rien je pense
poubelle n'en ramassé une reconduction
de la grève qui est annoncée jusqu'au 20
mars alors cette situation peut
entraîner des risques sanitaires
conséquents bien sûr aggravé par la
recrudescence de la présence des rats
appelé les surmulots à Paris dans les
espaces publics de la capitale monsieur
le ministre les Parisiens sont en colère
pourtant la mairie de Paris
personne ne semble s'en émouvoir madame
Hidalgo a même annoncé son soutien
entier et total au mouvement social et
oui
ça a été constatant c'est inertie la
chef de fil de l'opposition à Paris
madame Rachida Dati vous a saisi hier
vous avez donc chargé monsieur le
ministre le préfet de police de demander
à la mère de Paris de réquisitionner les
moyens matériels et en personnels
nécessaires au ramassage des poubelles
en réponse ce matin le premier adjoint
de Madame Hidalgo affirme que c'est le
gouvernement qui a créé cette situation
quel dé
quelle mauvaise volonté alors Monsieur
le Ministre quand l'État va-t-il se
substituer à la mairie de Paris pour
régler cette situation et surtout dans
quel délai
pour vous répondre
la parole d'un monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les outre-mer monsieur
Darmanin merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sellatrice vous connaissez déjà tout
à la suite de neuf jours de grève et
chacun a pu constater qu'il soit
parisien d'occasion ou parisiens
d'habitude l'annoncellement dans
certains arrondissements de Paris d'un
certain nombre de poubelles que vous
avez qualifiez-vous de plusieurs
milliers de d'autonnes posent des
questions pour la sécurité évidemment de
nos concitoyens ou on va même d'ailleurs
où il y a des manifestations mais pose
aussi des questions de salubrité
publique que chacun peut constater et
pour avoir été comme beaucoup ici
gestionnaire d'une collectivité locale
chacun peut voir ce que c'est
qu'attendre 9 jours et voir des milliers
de tonnes d'ordures et de poubelles
effectivement être sur la voie publique
j'ai donc demandé mais au nom de la
salubrité publique puisque mise à
l'intérieur est en charge d'un tutelle
sur le préfet de police la préfecture de
police
et après avoir contacté évidemment
Madame la Maire de Paris après avoir été
saisi vous avez évoqué Madame Dati en
effet par plusieurs mères
d'arrondissement mais aussi par
plusieurs élus parisiens quel que soit
leur bord politique après avoir été
saisi par eux j'ai donc demandé à Madame
Hidalgo d'abord évidemment à l'oral et
ensuite ce matin par la terminale
préfecture de police par écrit de
pouvoir faire ce que le droit lui permet
de faire notamment que la mairie de
Paris a fait pendant 10 de la loi
travail puisque il y a déjà eu
effectivement une situation similaire de
réquisitionner la question qui relève à
la fois du relèvement du des poubelles
qui sont relevées pardon de l'espace
public comme de l'incinération parce
qu'il s'agit bien des deux sujets à
l'oral j'ai entendu en effet ce matin le
premier adjoint évoqué le fait qu'il ne
serait pas favorable à cette situation
j'attends évidemment que Madame Laure de
Paris réponde par écrit à la demande par
écrit du préfet de police et si ce soir
cette confirmation a été faite la mairie
de Paris ne prenait pas ses
responsabilités je le dis ce soir demain
matin au plus tard le préfet de police
propose possédera réquisition
le nom de la salubrité publique et je
crois que tous les parisiens quel que
soit ce qu'ils pensent de la réforme des
retraites en seront heureux
madame Dumas
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
de votre réponse c'est vrai qu'à chaque
grève Paris s'enfonce un peu plus dans
l'insalubrité dans laquelle Anne Hidalgo
et ses alliés ont plongé les Parisiens
nous sommes aujourd'hui à moins de 500
jours de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
l'image de notre pays et de sa capitale
est durablement dégradée auprès des
touristes et des observateurs étrangers
qui sont sidérés il est donc grand temps
d'agir merci
la parole est au président Laurent
Laffont pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
porte sur le devenir du Stade de France
et s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame la ministre vous
avez annoncé il y a quelques jours que
l'État travaillait dans deux directions
soit la session du Stade de France soit
le renouvellement d'un système de
concession déjà en vigueur depuis 25 ans
le gouvernement n'a pas arrêté à ce jour
son choix entre ces deux options qui
sont
significativement différentes de fait le
Trésor a engagé de manière inédite de
procédures parallèles l'une pouvant
aboutir à la vente du Stade de France
l'autre pouvant aboutir au
renouvellement de système de concession
alors que les deux procédures sont
lancées les objectifs du gouvernement
quant à l'avenir du Stade de France
n'apparaissent pas encore clairement
aussi madame la ministre je souhaite
vous poser quatre questions précises
pour que vous nous éclairiez sur les
intentions
du gouvernement la première avez-vous eu
des engagements de la part des deux
principales fédérations sportives
utilisatrices du Stade de France le
football et le rugby contre à une
atteignisation à minima du stade et dans
quelles conditions financières le
souhaite-t-elle le faire la deuxième
question porte sur l'athlétisme qui
n'apparaît plus dans les consultations
lancées par le Trésor les deux dernières
portent enfin sur la session concernant
la session pourriez-vous nous préciser
quels sont les critères qui pourraient
vous amener à choisir la session plutôt
que la concession et enfin dernière
question est-ce que l'État français
serait prêt à vendre le Stade de France
à une structure appartement appartenant
pardon à un État étranger Stade de
France qui est devenu depuis la Coupe du
Monde de 98 et avec les Jeux Olympiques
dans quelques mois un emblème du sport
français
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre des Sports des Jeux Olympiques
para
vous avez la parole monsieur
le prénom c'est donner une boussole qui
est de faire émerger le meilleur projet
de long terme avec méthode et
transparence pour le Stade de France
avec deux exigences préserver la
vocation sportive du stade et une
deuxième qui est de préserver les
intérêts économiques et financiers de
l'État alors vous l'avez dit deux
procédures ont été lancées en parallèle
vous m'avez posé quatre questions
précises je vais essayer d'y répondre
s'agissant des fédérations elles sont
libres de candidater elles sont libres
de s'associer à un candidat ils sont
libres de négocier les conditions
d'utilisation du stade ce qui est
important c'est qu'elle puisse échanger
avec l'ensemble des candidats dans le
respect de l'équité et du droit de la
concurrence s'agissant de la piste
d'athlétisme les deux avis
précise bien mentionne bien la capacité
d'accueillir des grands événements
sportifs internationaux l'athlétisme est
un exemple
là il faudra voir ce que proposeront les
candidats s'agissant des meilleures
solutions et des meilleures options
prises sur ce terrain des grands
événements sportifs sur les différents
critères il y en a deux qui sont
expressément posés dans les deux avis un
critère davantage économique global pour
l'État et un critère qui est plus
commercial et technique relatifs
notamment à l'amélioration de l'accueil
du stade et notamment de l'attractivité
de ce stade dans son territoire
s'agissant de votre question sur un
investisseur étranger s'il devait y en
avoir un qui réponde aux conditions
protectrices qui dans le cas d'une
session serait de toute façon fixée par
la loi et Parlement ou si il devait cet
investisseur étranger participer à un
groupement plus simplement d'opérateurs
il n'y a pas de raison de l'en empêcher
de l'écarter a priori et par principe
mais ce que je veux vraiment dire c'est
projet ambitieux de long terme à la
hauteur de la place de pas dans le récit
sportif national des attentes des élus
et des habitants de ce territoire je
vous remercie
monsieur Lafont
la parole est à notre collègue Frédéric
puissat pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
de Paris la paramétique ou des fils
athlètes sur 6 km est un lourd des
filles en matière de sécurité le budget
que leur annoncé maîtrisé à hauteur de 8
milliards d'euros sans de plus en plus
difficiles à tenir et la France n'a pas
droit à l'erreur mais ma question porte
sur une autre difficulté celle qui
concerne la situation et la capacité
d'accueil des hôpitaux pendant que ce
dérouleront les Jeux Olympiques cet été
pour ce qui concerne les 15000 athlètes
et ceux qui les accompagnent un centre
de santé sera créé en lien avec l'APHP
mais pour ce qui concerne les plus de 10
millions de visiteurs attendus que
compte faire le gouvernement les
hôpitaux de Parisiens ont en temps
normal peine à fonctionner les services
d'urgence sont débordés et trop de lits
de chirurgie sont aujourd'hui fermés
ajoutons de surcroît qu'en plein été en
raison des congés les équipes médicales
sont réduites gouverner c'est prévoir
alors Monsieur le Ministre qu'avez-vous
prévu pour assurer le fonctionnement des
hôpitaux parisien pour faire face aux
soins courants et à la fin de visiteurs
pendant les Jeux Olympiques merci pour
vous répondre la parole et communiste de
la santé de la prévention Monsieur
François Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice puissant autour de la première
ministre le gouvernement est totalement
mobilisé autour de la ministre des
Sports pour faire de la Coupe du monde
de rugby également mais des Jeux
Olympiques bien entendu et paralympiques
la grande fête sportive qui doivent être
alors dans ce cadre plus global mon
ministère est concentré sur trois points
vous en avez appelé un j'en préciserai
deux autres le premier c'est bien sûr de
maintenir l'accès aux soins l'accès aux
soins sur les territoires concernés par
les Jeux Olympiques que ce soit à
l'Île-de-France mais n'oublions pas
aussi les hauts de France et PACA qui
vont être directement concernés cet
accès aux soins il est pour les
Franciliens par exemple bien entendu des
gens qui habitent à côté des sites
olympiques et pour cela nous mobilisons
le public le privé la médecine libérale
l'ensemble de nos partenaires pour
pouvoir assurer cette réponse qui a
évalué vous parliez des services
d'urgence nous évaluons à plus 5% de
fréquentation pendant cette période à
titre d'exemple
trois autres publics sont
particulièrement concernés nous sommes
attentifs au touristes qui vont arriver
à ce moment-là il y a des questions de
prise en charge bien sûr financière mais
il y a aussi des questions de traduction
qu'il faut prendre en compte les
sportifs et leur staff ont des parcours
de soins qui vont être identifiés pour
une croise pas les publics de
spectateurs et puis enfin les personnes
en situation de handicap doivent
bénéficier de parcours de soins
parfaitement identifié le deuxième point
que nous travaillons c'est celui des
situations sanitaires exceptionnelles le
risque climatique nous serons endettés
les risques infectieux les risques
nerbaissés et le risque également de
cybersécurité de cyberacaq avec la mise
en place de contre-mesures enfin le
troisième point c'est celui de
l'héritage des Jeux Olympiques cet
héritage c'est le sport santé le
président de la République a annoncé que
2024 le sport serait grande cause
nationale dans ce cadre-là le
déploiement encore plus important du
sport santé en termes de prévention
puisque c'est un axe fort de la
politique de mon ministère va nous
permettre d'améliorer l'état de santé
globale de nos concitoyens voici les
trois axes sur lesquels nous travaillons
actuellement de façon extrêmement
précise je vous remercie
préventive parce que les Français ont
trop souffert du fiasco du Stade de
France à l'occasion de la finale de la
Ligue des champions alors c'est vrai que
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
comme le président de la République nous
souhaitons des médailles mais nous
souhaitons surtout être sur les plus
hautes marches du podium en matière
d'organisation organisation des Jeux
Olympiques organisation de la santé
pendant les Jeux Olympiques organisation
de la santé aussi dans nos territoires
et dans nos départements au quotidien
pour tous les Français merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
Durin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez écrit
le 3 mars aux fonctionnaires de police
pour répondre aux inquiétudes qui se
sont exprimées derrière le slogan sauver
la pégypte Clémenceau ce courrier a été
rédigé avant même que le rapport du
Sénat soit rendu public la mission que
j'ai eu l'honneur de mener avec ma
collègue Nadine beluro au nom de la
commission des lois avait pourtant émis
22 recommandations adopté à l'unanimité
pour vous aider à faire cette réforme
nécessaire vous ne les avez pas entendu
vous les avez d'ailleurs à peine attendu
vous vouliez aller vite mais vous n'avez
pas réussi à rassurer les pjistes qui
continuent à exprimer publiquement leur
écureuiland vous deviez restaurer
l'attractivité de la filière PJ vous
confortez des envies d'émissions vous
n'avez pas davantage rassurer les
avocats les magistrats qui se joindront
au péjiste demain partout en France pour
manifester dans les tribunaux mais
surtout vous n'avez répondu à aucun des
quatre rapports qui ont été rendus sur
le sujet les inspections ont évoqué
l'insuffisance du cadrage initial de
l'expérimentation notre collègue
Dominati pour la commission des finances
vous appelez à ne pas déshabiller la PJ
à l'Assemblée nationale les deux
rapporteurs n'ont pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord monsieur bernali 6 craignant
une mise à mal du principe
d'indépendance de la police judiciaire
ici enfin au Sénat où nous avons proposé
un moratoire jusqu'au Jeux Olympiques il
vous permettrait d'améliorer votre copie
tout en évitant de fragiliser notre
appareil sécuritaire avant l'échéance de
2024 pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre
avez-vous rejeté ce conseil éclairé du
Sénat
pour la parole de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin
merci Monsieur Président Madame et
Messieurs les Durin merci pour votre
question permettez-moi de vous dire
d'abord que c'est une réforme très
importante que celle de la réforme de la
police nationale vous-même vous l'avez
souligné dans votre rapport avec Madame
belureau comme l'Assemblée nationale la
souligné puisque depuis 60 ans il n'y a
pas eu de réformes de la police
nationale à ce point structurantes et en
effet elle fait naître des
interrogations des questions et bien sûr
bouscu des habitudes auxquelles le
ministère d'intérieur et singulièrement
le ministre que je suis et
particulièrement attentif je constate
d'ailleurs que le Sénat dans sa très
grande majorité vous-même d'ailleurs
c'est que le groupe socialiste a adopté
le principe de cette réforme puisque
vous avez voté vous le savez bien la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et je crois de l'avant
co-construite ensemble saguièrement sur
la question de la réforme de la police
nationale alors vous dites que nous
n'avons pas pris connaissance et compte
de vos propositions permettez-moi de
dire monsieur le sénateur que c'est faux
il est vrai que j'ai refusé d'attendre
la fin des Jeux Olympiques pour mettre
en place une réforme qui est travaillée
depuis le ministre Jox ce qui ne
rajeunira pas grand monde ici bien
évidemment et qui par ailleurs et
travailler depuis plus de deux ans et
demi par le ministre de l'Intérieur que
je suis et qui avait déjà été imaginé
par des prédécesseurs dans le fameux
Livre Blanc sur l'intégralité des autres
dispositions nous vous suivons monsieur
le sénateur les EPG de rond
systématiquement être PJ bien sûr c'est
le cas la formation en particulier des
DPN est prévue nous avons travaillé avec
le ministre de la Justice bien sûr pour
que l'évaluation se fasse avec les
procureurs de la République pour les
ddpn nous travaillons d'ailleurs avec
une lettre conjointe pour rappeler qu'un
article 12 du code de procédure pénale
soit évidemment que les magistrats puis
saisir les services d'enquête et ce ne
sont pas des préfets qui le feront le
fait que nous serions au rendez-vous des
désépn qui pourront travailler en lien
avec les dipn que j'évoquais dans le
courrier je pense que c'est au
rendez-vous également vous suggérer
l'état des lieux du stock des procédures
s'élève dans votre proposition numéro
une avec le garder son nous avons confié
une mission suite notamment à vos
interpellations les moyens spécialisés
pour les directions régionales c'est
votre profession numéro 4 c'est
effectivement le cas les magistrats
devant saisir
directement les offices centraux c'est
déjà le cas pour conclure et oui
monsieur le Président j'attendais votre
rappel pour dire qu'à quel point je ne
peux sous citer toutes les bonnes
propositions que nous suivons de la part
du sénateur du Rhin
que des monsieur le ministre toutes ces
bonnes propositions ne sont pas tombées
dans l'oreille des pjistes et si nous
vous imprimons si nous exprimons une une
inquiétude c'est que notre conviction et
notre crainte c'est que sans PJ nous ne
gagnerons pas la guerre contre la drogue
sans PJ nous ne lutterons pas
efficacement contre la criminalité
organisée notamment économique et
financière nous craignons que la
dilution de l'expertise de la PJ que le
tout voit public ne soit une impasse
tout comme le rétrécissement
départemental et là prend la prise en
main de l'administratif sur le
judiciaire alors oui monsieur le
ministre comme les péjist vous le disent
comme les magistraldies pour la sécurité
des Français sauver la PJ
merci la parole est à notre collègue
bruno Sido pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
la Cour des comptes dans son dernier
rapport préconise la réduction du nombre
de communes et notamment les plus
petites d'entre elles les gouvernements
successifs par le biais de différentes
lois se sont attaqués régulièrement au
nombre de communes en France toutefois
je tiens à rappeler que le fait communal
est le fait départemental précèdent le
fer républicain la loi de 1971
dites-lois Marcelin a voulu faire
fusionner les communes sans grands
succès et d'autres lois similaires ont
été votées par la suite j'ajouterai que
comme on n'est pas prophète en son pays
monsieur marceelin a fait zéro fusion
association dans son département par
exemple dans mon département par contre
la Haute-Marne avec cette loi 200
communes ont souhaitées
mais la moitié d'entre elles ont divorcé
l'année suivante aujourd'hui les
communes sont attaquées sous l'angle
financier afin d'assainir les finances
publiques de l'État en se basant sur les
chiffres de 20 européens année paradoxal
où les investissements des collectivités
ont été très réduits à cause de la crise
covid monsieur le ministre bien que ce
que de la ce que dit la Cour des comptes
soit rarement entendu par les
gouvernements quel est votre position
sur l'analyse de ce qu'elle préconise
on vous répond la parole est au ministre
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bruno
Sido
à l'évocation du fait que chez Marcellin
n'a pas été prophète en son pays je veux
convoquer la présidente de roche le
sénateur pied-noir le sénateur Bigot et
le sénateur Emmanuel Capu puisque le
département du Maine-et-Loire et celui
dans lequel il y a eu le plus de fusion
de communes 48% des communes ont
fusionné au point qui nous reste 186
communes sur les 358 que nous avions
mais quand je vous aurais précisé qu'il
ne s'agit quand je vous aurais précisé
qu'il ne s'agit que de mariage d'amour
et que je vous aurais dit qu'en matière
de fusion je ne crois pas au mariage qui
ne sont pas des mariages d'amour je vous
aurais précisé ce qui est une partie de
ma philosophie en pensant qu'il faut pas
plaquer un modèle national sur ces
sujets les concerts on les connaît les
constats c'est d'expliquer que nous
avions en 1790 44000 communes que nous
n'en avions que nous en avions encore 38
000 en 1960 et qu'on est rendu que à
34000 et qu'il n'y a eu que 235 fusions
de communes depuis 2014
pourtant un certain nombre de PPL je
pense à la PPLC de haut je pense à la
PPL Gatel ce sont les forcés de regarder
comment donner un statut aux communes
associées aux communes déléguées pour
éviter que ce soit tout ou rien
notre conviction et j'associe Dominique
fort dont vous savez l'attachement aux
communes en particulier aux communes
rurales en particulier c'est que rien
dans ce domaine ne se fera par la
contrainte
l'intercommunalité est une chance à
condition qu'on ait les conférences des
maires et les packs de gouvernance dans
certains cas il faut rendre possible les
fusion en montrant ce qu'elle permettent
mais il ne faut pas qu'elle soit forcée
sinon elles aboutissent à la fin à des
choses qui sont plus mauvaises quelle
doit être notre obsession c'est faire en
sorte qu'on ait des mutualisations qui
permettent d'améliorer la vie des
habitants sur le territoire et le
meilleur usage des deniers publics dans
certains endroits ça peut passer par des
fusions dans d'autres par des
coopérations intercommunales dans
d'autres encore par des modes
d'association qui dépendent on peut pas
à la fois expliquer qu'on leur fait
confiance et projeter un modèle qui
serait le même partout en faisant fille
de notre histoire et de nos réalités
locales
aujourd'hui Monsieur le Ministre les
Français sont plus que jamais attachés
alors comme une la crise des gilets
jaunes la crise sanitaire sont passées
par là et ont démontré l'importance de
ces 500 000 élus qui travaillent qui
administrent leur commune les mers et
leurs adjoints les conseils municipaux
bien souvent tous ces élus sont
bénévoles et font même beaucoup les
travaux à titre gracieux rappelons-nous
ce couple mère très fait le premier
ministre Jean Castex vantait le mérite
des mers comme des piliers de la
République on les applaudissait pour
leur implication mais aujourd'hui face
au poids des finances publiques on
voudrait les sacrifier je voudrais vous
dire Monsieur le Ministre que votre
réponse ne va pas convaincu alors je
repose ma question allez-vous faire
payer aux petites communes le laxisme
budgétaire du gouvernement en les
supprimant
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Stéphane quesnoir pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à la ministre de la
transition énergétique en l'espace d'une
année la problématique des coûts de
l'énergie vous le savez est devenu
crucial pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens nous entreprises et même nos
collectivités locales dans ce contexte
le Mans à légiférer c'est son rôle et la
loi du 16 août 2022 prévoit que le prix
de l'accès régulier à l'énergie
nucléaire historique la reine ne peut
être inférieure à 49,50 € du
mégawattheure désormais puis
curieusement le gouvernement a introduit
l'obligation de soumettre cette
disposition à l'avis de la Commission
européenne ce que le Conseil d'État dans
son délibéré du 3 février dernier a
formellement identifié comme
inutile puisque ce prix de 49,50 € et
largement inférieur au prix du marché
et non seulement le gouvernement semble
être sourd à cette objection du Conseil
d'État mais vous n'avez à ce jour même
pas solliciter la Commission européenne
monsieur ou madame la ministre je ne
sais pas qui me répondra pouvez-vous
donner les raisons de cette surdité
gouvernementale matinée procrastination
bien étonnante
alors pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué
en charge des petites les voyants
entreprises du commerce et de
l'artisanat
monsieur le sénateur pied-noir j'ai
l'honneur d'essayer de vous répondre ma
collègue la ministre Agnès et dans ce
moment même à l'Assemblée nationale sur
le projet de loi nucléaire et s'excuse
de son absence et pourquoi je vais
essayer de répondre à votre question
pertinente et technique avec les
éléments dont je dispose et je ne doute
pas qu'elle y apportera d'autres
éléments à la suite dans cette fin de
journée je vais quand même rappeler
indépendamment des procédures que vous
mentionnez et de la saisine et des
réactions du Conseil d'État la
mobilisation du gouvernement français
à l'endroit de notre mix énergétique et
nos travaux en cours avec la Commission
européenne pour faire avancer aussi la
réforme du marché de de l'énergie vous
rappelez quand même à quel point nous
nous continuons à investir massivement
dans le nucléaire 4 à 5 milliards
d'euros par an au niveau d'EDF 50
milliards d'euros depuis 2015 pour le
grand carénage 6 EPR 2 pour 50 milliards
d'euros et à l'international vous le
savez avec inc l'État n'a pas lésiné il
a recapitalisé par deux fois depuis 2015
EDF près de 4 milliards 2017 3 milliards
en 2022 et vous le savez nous
construisons des nouveaux réacteurs les
travaux sont en cours et nous l'avons
dit Agnès panière une hladi l'État sera
au rendez-vous les Français dans cette
situation dans voler des prix de
l'électricité sont protégés face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie vous avez
mentionné la reine qui peu importe ce
qu'on dit le Conseil d'État est quand
même un dispositif qui aujourd'hui
protège massivement nos concitoyens mais
aussi une bonne partie de nos
entreprises je pense aussi aux bouclier
et tarifaires vous le savez aux aides
énergies je voudrais vous ajouter
quelques points nous n'avons rien lâché
sur la réforme du marché européen de
l'énergie après un an de travail et de
mobilisation notamment de Bruno Le Maire
mais aussi Daniel panier runachet la
Commission a proposé formellement une
réforme qui reprend trois demandes
françaises majeures à laquelle vous êtes
sensible des contrats pour différences
entre les producteurs et tous les
consommateurs pour que l'électricité
soit vendu un prix proche des coûts de
production nationale les éligibilité du
nucléaire assez contrats l'éligibilité
des installations existantes comme c'est
le cas pour la plupart des centrales en
France c'est une nouvelle encourageante
une bonne base de travail à cette heure
et notre objectif et qu'elle soit
adoptée cette année je vous remercie
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
je sais l'implication du gouvernement
même si elle est récente en faveur de la
relance de la filière nucléaire de notre
pays mais cela passe par des moyens à
consolider pour notre outil industriel
qui doit accomplir cette ce programme
nucléaire à savoir EDF qui doit faire
face à une dette colossale de 64
milliards d'euros qui doit faire face à
un mur d'investissement dans les années
à venir et cela lucrémond déclarait
lui-même que ce ne sera pas possible si
le prix de la reine reste fixé à 42
euros du mégawater
une reconnaissait elle-même que le prix
de production par EDF était aux
alentours de 58 euros donc on va bien
qu'il y a un delta qui qui est important
et je demande au gouvernement un minimum
de cohérence vous savez qu'il est encore
temps de prendre les mesures nécessaires
d'une part pour ne plus bafouer les
décisions du Parlement de piétiner ses
décisions vous avez actuellement je vous
le rappelle un véhicule législatif à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vous permet de
les faire de le faire je vous invite à
vous en saisir merci merci
[Applaudissements]
avec les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement merci madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
de la promotion de loi visant adapter la
défense extérieure contre l'incendie à
la réalité des territoires ruraux la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne parmi les
temps forts cette semaine on retient
cette gauche sénatoriale qui monte au
créneau une nouvelle fois contre la
réforme des retraites cette gauche qui
dénonce la déconnexion entre la France
qui manifeste en nombre encore
aujourd'hui avec cette huitième journée
de mobilisation et de l'autre le
Parlement notamment la droite
sénatoriale qui vote la réforme écoutez
la question de la présidente du groupe
communiste au Sénat et Liana SSI
les victoires de 95 face à la réforme
des retraites de Monsieur Juppé de 2006
pour effacer le CPE non-elle pas
confirmer la force du mouvement social
et sa légitimité oui madame la Première
ministre il existe une légalité
résultant d'une élection mais il existe
une légitimité sociale que vous ne
pouvez pas nier et qui aujourd'hui
s'impose à vous
oui vous entendez un dans ces propos
d'Hélène SSI et bien cette dichotomie
entre l'égalité et légitimité lorsque la
gauche faisait et bien cette dichotomie
on entend envoyer la première ministre
qui faisait des noms de la tête sur le
banc des ministres qui bouillonnaient de
répondre à ces sénateurs de gauche
écouter un extrait d'une de ses réponses
il y a quelque chose de grave à opposé
systématiquement la légitimité de la rue
à celle du Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelque chose de dangereux à
tenter par tout moyen d'empêcher le
débat de le bloquer
[Applaudissements]
autrement fort quand la Première
ministre a fait le bilan des 10 jours de
l'examen de la réforme de retraite au
Sénat et selon elle aussi il y aura un
avant et un après réforme des retraites
écoutez à nouveau Isabelle évidemment
j'aurais préféré plus de débats de fonds
et moins de procédures plus de débats
d'idées et moins de posture vous en avez
décidé autrement je le regrette mais
c'est ainsi et c'est le fait unique de
ce qui devient la nuit pêche sénatoriale
[Applaudissements]
voilà et de son côté la gauche
sénatoriale qui est déjà en train de se
projeter dans l'après après réforme de
retraite au Parlement puisqu'elle entend
bien dénoncer cette réforme au Conseil
constitutionnel merci merci beaucoup
Quentin pour toutes ces explications et
tout de suite on va partir salle des
conférences
qui était donc au cœur de cette échange
très important lors de cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement est un micro
d'Alexandre poussea oui bonjour et
bienvenue qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
la première ministre qui estime que
c'est dangereux d'opposer la rue au
Parlement vous savez j'ai trouvé que le
ton de madame la Première ministre
c'était assez agressif et qui se pour
moi c'est véritablement un signe de
fébrilité de la part du gouvernement et
un signe aussi de perdition je crois que
le gouvernement aujourd'hui ne sait plus
où il habite excusez-moi de l'expression
ils sont perdus au regard de ce qui se
passe quand même dans la rue depuis oui
dans la rue depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant et donc voilà une sorte de de
faiblesse politique en fait qui
s'exprime par la voix de la première
ministre et je trouve ça vraiment
regrettable vous avez évoqué et bien des
procédures légales utilisées par le
gouvernement mais peut-être un manque de
légitimité si cette réforme des
retraites demain est votée par le
Parlement elle ne sera pas légitime oui
ne sera pas lég parce qu'elle a elle a
été installée dans une une procédure qui
est le 47,1 donc et il y a plusieurs
mesures de cette de cette réforme des
retraites qui n'a strictement rien à
voir avec un projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale donc
nous allons laisser le Conseil
constitutionnel donné son avis sur ces
sur ce point mais sur d'autres aussi qui
sont dans le texte donc oui pour nous ce
texte et illégique il est illégitime
parce que nous pensons que
constitutionnellement il est à côté des
clous et nous pensons qu'il est
illégitime parce qu'il n'a pas de
majorité dans le pays donc les
parlementaires de gauche vont saisir
très prochainement le Conseil
constitutionnel
nous sommes là aussi dans les clous dans
les starting block il y a également une
autre un autre recours qui va être
utilisé par les parlementaires de gauche
c'est le référendum d'initiative
partagée ça y est vous allez lancer
un recours c'est une une procédure que
nous donne la constitution de de 2008
dans la révision de la Constitution il y
a eu en 2008 donc nous utilisaient ce
que la Constitution nous permet et donc
effectivement l'éventualiser
l'éventualité pardon de déposer un RIB
sur cette réforme j'ai bon espoir qu'on
y arrive ça devrait se faire dans les
quelques heures et puis